I'm gen Brian and I'm the host of the
Congressional dish podcast and I'm
filling in today for David because he's
on his way to Sin City and he's going to
be reporting to you from Vegas for the
rest of the week but today I've been
telling you the story of the omnibus
funding law and how it became law and
there's one last piece of the how the
omnibus became lost story that just made
me aware of something that I didn't know
before and you probably didn't know
either because who tells us these things
and so to get a bit wonky for a second
the way the omnibus was able to move
faster through the process is that it
was basically attached to a bill that
had already passed both the House and
the Senate the bill was numbered HR 1625
and so if you look up the the omnibus
now it says that this HR 1625 but it
wasn't always it used to be a completely
different bill and so the original text
was one that actually did become law as
a part of an the omnibus so I figured I
might as well tell you about it the
original text was called the target Act
which stands for targeted rewards for
the global eradication of human
trafficking and the changes that it
makes to the law is there actually no
big deal but it's what it changes the
program that already exists that I found
out about reading this and just went
like what the hell so what the target
Act does is it adds human trafficking to
the definition of transnational
organized crime in order to allow the
State Department to pay people who give
information to the State Department
information that leads to arrests of
criminals and so essentially what it
does is it allows money to be paid to
stitches and I didn't know that the
State Department had a program for
paying snitches apparently it does and
so this bill just adds one more thing
that people can snitch about now this
cash first snitches program allows the
State Department to appropriate quote
such amounts as may be necessary unquote
which is kind of unusual I mean I read
these bills a lot and it's kind of
unusual for an agency to determine its
own funding levels it's generally what
Congress is four and then these payments
I looked up the caps so I was like how
much are we paying these people well
they're capped at 25 million dollars
except us personally authorized by the
Secretary of State which as of right now
is no one but for the last year or so
it's been Rex Tillerson the the former
president and CEO of Exxon Mobil so god
only knows who he was paying so yeah
twenty five million dollars is the cap
but the cap is actually 50 million
dollars for information leading to the
capture of a leader of a foreign
terrorist organization 50 million
dollars and then another thing I found
kind of fascinating is that payments
under $100,000 don't need approval at
all from the Secretary of State and I
one last thing that I found disturbing
is that these decisions made by the
Secretary of State are final and are not
allowed to be reviewed by the courts so
this is a disturbing program and it
wasn't always like this because I looked
up the original law the original law was
created in 1984 which kind of ironic ID
maybe for if you've read that book but
the original law was written in 1984 and
it allowed payments to be capped at half
a million dollars so we've gone from
half a million dollars to fifty million
dollars in payments first snitches and
then all the payments back then needed
approval but payments over a hundred
thousand dollars had to be approved by
the President himself
so now the same number a hundred
thousand dollars or more has to be
approved by the Secretary of State who
again is no one and it used to be that
the President himself had to be
approving these so this is this is just
a much bigger program than was ever
intended and I think it just goes to
show how far off the rails Congress has
gone since the beginning of the war on
terror today's program is sponsored in
part by shaker and spoon a monthly
cocktail subscription box delivering the
full craft cocktail experience right to
your door they send you the ingredients
for three completely new and original
craft cocktail recipes enough for 12
cocktails should be enough to get you
through the whole month I got the death
by gin box meaning I got the ingredients
for three
forant gin-based cocktails and I'm able
to go and choose the brand of spirit
that I want I happen to go with a
particularly dry gin in addition to
sending really clear recipe cards for
each recipe in the box you can also
watch the supplemental how-to videos by
shaker and spoon which is useful
sometimes I admit I don't exactly know
the difference between shaken stirred
and who knows what other options there
are I'm generally clueless so for me I
need the Supplemental how-to videos and
for a limited time our audience can get
$20 off by going to shaker and spoon
comm slash Pakman if you're watching
this on YouTube I've put a link in the
description underneath this video and
you can check out the how-to videos on
YouTube as well